[Applause]
thank you thank you very much thanks for
coming out and it's great to be here
tonight
RJ Giulia is one of the the gems of
independent book selling on the eastern
seaboard and I'm really happy to be here
in the other room I was chatting with
someone and they were asking me of how I
came to develop an interest in Jay Gould
how I came to circle in on on this topic
zero in on this target and it's it's
interesting it's kind of a it's Gould
has been lurking on my mind for a good
12 13 14 years I in 1992 I published a
biography of a an obscure tune of the
century naturalist and writer by the
name of John Burroughs who published
about 27 books between 1874 1921 and who
was a great friend and protege of an
Walt Walt Whitman Ralph Waldo Emerson so
on and so forth and who was also a great
friend of Theodore Roosevelt's and wrote
a book about Roosevelt and Burroughs had
grown ups on an adjacent impoverished
farm in the Catskill Mountains of New
York beside Jay Gould they were poor
farm boys together and each had gone off
into the world and each had become a
success and each had lost track of the
other boroughs making his way in the
world of literature and arts googled
making his way more than making his way
in the realm of finance and they didn't
have much contact with each other
although they'd been great friends as
kids and but they never had a
falling-out they never had an argument
that anyone was aware of they just went
off on their separate roads as so many
of us do and when I was researching the
Burroughs book I spent some time in jail
private library at his mansion Lyndhurst
on Tarrytown New York on the Hudson
River and in Gould library his
well-thumbed library that he read
through extensively in his own time
I found a complete set of the works of
John Burroughs up until 1892 which is
the year when Gould died and in some of
the books where Burroughs wrote about
his childhood experiences in the
Catskills and especially where Burroughs
wrote about trout fishing in the
Catskills and endeavor in which he'd
partnered with Jay Gould on more than
one occasion I found all sorts of
scribbled marginalia in the book I
remember this Creek he's got this wrong
that you know the beaver kill was better
than the Esopus he doesn't know what
he's he's not remembering correctly and
and that kind that discovery sort of
humanized Gould for me and and got me
interested in him as as a human being
and as a got me interested in probing
below the the veneer of of the
stereotype Gould and finding out what
was really going on with him I'm going
to talk tonight I'm going to be doing
some talking and a little reading out of
the book and sort of dovetailing in
between doing those two things to try
and give you a sense of the book and
also to try and give you a sense of
where I come from in the book and how I
how I approach Gould Gould have lived
from 1836 to 1892 he died at a very
young age he died at the age of 56
killed by tuberculosis which had stopped
not only him for years about his father
and many other members of his family for
few years it ran ran and it was in the
genes and my book begins where I will
also been begin tonight my book begins
at the end my book begins with we
Jay Gould dead of Jay Gould horizontal
and here we go on the evening of
December 5th 1892 outside a townhouse at
the northeast corner of 47th Street and
Fifth Avenue a stray adventurer did a
good business selling freshly printed
calling cards bearing the chiselled name
of one of the sons edwin gould this will
get you in dead certain the vendor
assured those who forked over their $2
notes then he vanished with his profits
just as his first customers were brusque
ly shown the door and the balance
refused admittance old Jay Gould who
they stiffened cold in the living room
of 579 Fifth Avenue would have applauded
both the hucksters boldness and his
while Jay had always believed that
shrewd aptitude should be rewarded and
its absence punished he despised fools
this fact was well known to the men who
jostled through the crowd to present
their more genuine credentials Russell
Sage JP Morgan William Rockefeller
inside standing by the casket Ogden
Mills was heard to compliment the
naturalness of the corpse a Butler told
Mills that Jays body had spent the
previous three days propped up in a
chest full of ice this accounted for the
healthy red flush of his cheeks Railway
tycoon Henry Villard studied the many
flowers including an orchid spray for
the coffin arranged to spell out the
word grandpa and commented how Jay would
have enjoyed them Jays love of flowers
said Villard no one in particular was
one of the few things that signaled his
humanity as he spoke the Lord pulled a
keepsake blossom from an ornate pastiche
of bloom sitting near the head of the
casket it was arranged in the form of a
ship
fully rigged inscribed with the words
voyage ended safe and port voyage ended
indeed the nation's newspapers
restlessly competed the summarize J's
strenuous circumnavigation of life and
business editors from Boston to San
Francisco vied to see who could come up
with the most pejorative turns of phrase
while those in Jays hometown would
scarcely move to defend him he exercised
a large influence over the careers of
many who had commercial aspirations
wrote Gould longtime nemesis James
Gordon Bennett jr. publisher of the New
York Herald Bennett continued to say
that Jays influence tended to lower the
moral tone of business transactions the
example he set is a dangerous one to
follow wrote Bennett the methods he
adopted are to be avoided his financial
success judged by the means by which it
was attained is not to be envied his
great wealth was purchased at too high a
price he played the game of life for
keeps and he regarded the possible ruin
of thousands as a matter in which he had
no concern then its competitors at the
New York Times used the occasion of
ghouls death to extol Astor at 80 Stuart
who quote in serving their own ends were
serving the public ends while Gould was
a negative quantity in the development
of the country ghouls fortune said the
times was based on his skill at quote
intercepting the earnings of other
people and diverting them from their
original destination over at the New
York world a paper Gould owned briefly
before selling it to Joseph Pulitzer
editorialists opined that quote 10,000
ruined men will curse the dead man's
memory convicts will wonder what mental
defect robbed them of such a career as
ghouls
the public has no great interest in the
death of Jay Gould because Jay Gould in
his life never showed any interest in
the public this is not a death that will
cause any public sorrow more than one
Minister that Sunday insisted that Gould
who had passed on December 2nd of Friday
was already burning to a terrible
crispness in the eternal fires of hell
was the human incarnation of avarice a
thief in the night stalking his fellow
man
so declared the rector of st. Paul's
Episcopal Church on Madison Avenue the
minister's flock nearly all of them old
moneyed aristocrats had hated Gould as
much for his audacious rise from poverty
as for the dark cunning of his business
transactions they believed that they
were all to a man better than him
despite his 72 million the bane of the
social intellectual and spiritual life
of America today is the idolatrous
homage to the Golden Calf the shouted an
editorial in the world nothing else has
contributed so much to promote this evil
condition as the worldly success of Jay
Gould we must refuse to practice and
disseminate the vices of which he was
the most conspicuous model in modern
times to this at least one Minister is
known to have added that little better
could have been expected from someone of
goulds race it was they said an age-old
story Gould would have been amused an
unenthusiastic presbyterian by birth and
a perfect area Episcopalian by marriage
the bearded financier had long
encouraged an entirely different view of
himself in an age of fashionable
anti-semitism Jay Jason Gould routinely
remained quiet when characterized in the
press as a self aggrandizing Jew a
[ __ ] Joseph Pulitzer who long before
had sought to shed his own Jewish
pedigree complained that quote the
mysterious bearded Gould was one of the
most sinister figures to have ever
flitted bat-like across the vision of
the American people at the same time
Henry Adams described his brothers
Charles Francis's archrival and
railroading as quote a complex Jew small
and slight in person dark sallow
reticent and stealthy Gould Himself
sardonically welcomed such descriptions
in life telling associates that his
quote presumed Hebraic origin
could only enhance his reputation as a
force against which resistance would
prove futile there is no record of what
ghouls only close Jewish friend Jesse
Seligman had to say about this coldly
rational analysis of how common
bigotries however reprehensible could be
used to one's advantage Seligmann was
among those who sat about the crepey
deck parlor of five seven nine Fifth
Avenue silently contemplating that most
rare of sights Jay Gould at rest Jay
Gould without an agenda here Gould lay
still and silent in his black walnut
casket surrounded by the small circle of
family and associates who understood him
far better than all the scribbling
journalists in the world put together
nevertheless the reporters continued to
scribble those who assembled never loved
the dead man and the dead man never
loved them so declared a writer for the
New York world as if he had cause to
know he had never loved any of his kind
saved those of his blood so what is the
cold truth that there was no sorrow by
his bier there was decent respect
nothing more to those presents however
the grief of the moguls seemed genuine
enough Seligmann was seen to cry white
law read publisher of the New York
Tribune the one newspaper that had been
conspicuously and consistently friendly
to Gould in his life hell J's door
eldest daughter
23 year old Helen known as Nellie to all
who knew her well in a long weeping
embrace for more than 30 minutes
Rockefellers sage and Valar joined
loudly in the hymns through much of the
afternoon the 28 year old George J Gould
who lacked not only his father's
slimness but also his rapid mind and his
personal discipline knelt and prayed
beside the corpse whether he prayed for
his father's immortal soul or for the
wit necessary to run the complex Empire
to which he now fell heir
no one knew most hoped
ever that George was at least smart
enough to pray for wit sitting near the
sobbing Nellie the other children
Edwin 25 Howard 20 on 16 and Frank who
just turned 15 two days before his
father's death all seemed quite taken
over by grief
they loved the man who was a Fink stew
most others money aside none of them
knew where they would go from here on
the morning of the 6th at 10:00
precisely for ghouls was always punctual
a somber procession of eight black
coaches departed for Woodlawn Cemetery
in the Bronx
one hour later the cortege pulled up
before a lush ionic mausoleum of granite
and marble set on a large tract of land
overlooking an ornamental lake Gould had
last been to this decorous place of
defeat built at a cost of 125,000
dollars in January of 1889 that morning
had been similar to this one Stern winds
biting cold and ice underfoot as
pallbearers carried the small broken
body of the first Helen Jays wife of 26
years to the Saral emptiness of the new
crypt as all who knew him realized Jays
grief at that time had been profound in
fact it had been total the ordeal has
changed him very much wrote a reporter
for the normally critical world it has
added to the slight stoop in his
shoulders and increased the careworn
look in his face mr. Gould himself is
not a well man his wife's death is a
great blow to him now nearly four years
later Jay returned to his Helen never
again to leave her side once within the
immense edifice of the Tomb Chancellor
Henry Mitchell McCracken of the city
unit McCracken of the University of a
city of New York destined to be renamed
New York University four years later
read a commitment prayer while behind
him two workmen prepared for a grim task
wearing thick insulated gloves the
workers held small pails of smoldering
lead
upon McCracken's signal they move
forward and spoonful by spoonful applied
the liquid to the cracks on all sides of
ghouls coffin before screwing down the
lid there was something indescribably
awful about that act ghouls nice Alice
Northrup remembered years later and it
was so slow so unmercifully slow then at
last the men laid the coffin of Jay
Gould in place beside that of his wife
and set the marble cover on the Crypt
Gould Zorn a tomb represented something
more than just a Gilded Age grasp at
Pharaoh like immortality it also
represented the final iteration and
logical end for the luxurious garrison
lifestyle to which Gould had become
accustomed over the long years The
Times's coverage of his internment did
not fail to note the presence on the
outskirts of the cemetery of a number of
unwashed long-haired men wearing red
neckerchiefs these malcontents
anarchists muttered and cursed and
seemed to send forth the promise of
violence still as they had always done
before they remained at bay furtively
eyeing the burly Pinkerton detectives
who arrived with the ghoul party and
remained on guard once the family
departed the Pinkertons a presence at
the unmarked Woodlawn tomb for the next
decade and the sealing of the coffin
were precautions not just against Malkin
sense but also against grave robbers
like those who had stolen and ransom the
body of a T Stewart some years before
but of course a few jaded types down in
New York's financial district offered a
different interpretation writing in The
Herald Bennet speculated that the guards
and the sealed casket were meant to keep
Gould from finding his way out and
retaining returning to raid Wall Street
one last time this the seed for this
cynicism had been planted some 23 years
earlier during the late summer and early
autumn of 1869 when Gould and his then
partner Jim Fisk had tried and failed in
an audacious bid
under the gold market their effort
touched off the infamous Black Friday
panic in which hundreds of investors
were ruined the demonization of Jay
Gould following the shipwreck of black
friday was strident and fanatical the
juggernaut of negative press launched in
late September of 1869 has yet to stop
as is evidenced by annual today in
history blurbs that routinely damned
Gould Seoul and newspapers nationwide
every September 24th in Gould zone era
1869 s images of roon men with their
implicit corollary of once prosperous
families demoted to lives of destitution
form the bedrock for a lasting
reputation as a jackal and betrayer
Gustavus Myers
an early Gould chronicler and critic
wrote that google quote became invested
with a sinister distinction as the most
cold-blooded corruption a spoil aider
and financial pirate of his time to the
end of his days this image confronted
him at every step and survived to become
the standing reproach in terror of his
descendants for nearly half a century
the very name of Jay Gould was a
persisting jeer and by word an object of
popular contumely and hatred the
significant of every foul and bass crime
by which greed triumphs strong language
the process began with the pot calling
the kettle black his touches death
commented the notorious Wall Street
Buccaneer Daniel drew with reference to
Gould thereafter similar dark metaphors
sprang up like mushrooms The Times's
financial reporter dub J the meth
estoppel ease of Wall Street cartoons
depicted him flying on bat wings horns
protruding through his top hat as he
scowled down on Trinity Church and Wall
Street the herald pointed out that jason
of myth was he who pursued the golden
fleece with such single-minded diligence
the sun went so far as to suggest a cow
Stian overtone - googled skill a pact
with evil that though it made Gould
former formidable in
this world would ultimately destroy him
in the next Wall Street operator James
arkeen no saint himself went on record
denouncing Gould as quote the worst man
on earth since the beginning of the
Christian era he is treacherous false
cowardly and a despicable worm incapable
of a generous nature meanwhile the
Tribune chastised Gould for squatting
drew like on the worst of his and Fisk's
gold contracts after Black Friday they
quote used lawyers and junctions to
prevent the payment of honest debts obey
the rules of the gold exchange when they
make it by it and repudiate when they
lose betray each other's counsels sell
out their Confederates and consent to
the ruin of their partners now although
Gould himself understood with painful
clarity that he'd ended the adventure of
the gold corner significantly poorer
than when he began it the everyday man
on the street would could not have been
convinced of this in the popular mind
Black Friday was a cataclysm
orchestrated superbly and controlled
completely by the cunning Gould for the
purpose of profiteering the uneducated
majority who tended to view capitalism
as a zero-sum game in which a dollar
lost by one player instant instantly
became one gained by another assume that
the specter of hundreds of bankrupted
investors equalled unrivaled and
unconscionable gains on the part of
Gould and his allies newspapers went
with the flow scandals simple ones
summarized in just a few outraged
paragraphs devoid of numbing
complexities added up to brisk sales for
Daly's nationwide in a market hungry for
a one-dimensional arch-villain of Wall
Street access Jay Gould suddenly fit the
bill all too well
later on long after Black Friday and
long after his and Fisk's ransacking of
the impossibly configured Erie Railroad
which every single owner nacho schools
had leveraged at one time or another
as a shell for manipulating capital the
legend of Gould
faith would allow him as he embarked
upon his life's real legitimate work
taking control of the Union Pacific and
the Missouri Pacific accumulating other
major roads in the southwest building up
the Gould system of rail raised
mastering the Western Union and
dominating the Manhattan elevated as
Morey Klein is written Google's infamy
coming off of Black Friday spread quote
like a lethal cloud across every
enterprise he touched for two decades in
the end no degree of managerial success
and no amount of hard-won profits built
up for shareholders over dozens upon
dozens of quarters would ever be enough
to mitigate the easy stereotype of the
thieving manipulator out to glut himself
on spoils flim-flam from unwitting
innocence the presumption of guilt was
to go with Jay to his tomb for the rest
of his life his motives which after all
were simply to make money the same as
any other capitalist would be suspect
and to him a higher standard of virtue
would always be applied in time the
press and public came to view the petty
ruses and gambits employed commonly by a
host of speculators on Wall Street as
despised tools of fraud and monopolies
whenever adopted by Gould in part this
was because of his reputation for
treachery but it was also because he
used the common tools of the street in
strikingly new ways putting together
previously unimaginable combinations
with a dexterity that spawned frustrated
envy on the part of bystanders some
fifteen years following Black Friday
long after Gould had proved himself a
steadfast CEO capable of working in
concert with a score of dedicated
long-term allies to maintain and expand
several major corporations at once the
Railroad Times of London would
nevertheless editorialize that ghouls
God quote is his pocket to fill which he
has prostituted every attribute with
which he is endowed like the Ishmaelite
of old his hand is against every man and
every man's
and is against him those who have
ventured to look upon him in the light
of a friend have invariably found sooner
or later that they had taken into their
bosom a serpent who sting his death but
to attempt to sketch the character of
mr. Jay Gould and its true colors would
be futile since no language is equal to
the task his cold heartless villainy
stands alone like the man himself who is
so ruthlessly swindled those whom he
regarded as his friends that he has now
none left to swindle now a few weeks
after Jay Gould entombment his friend
Jessie Seligman gave an interview to a
reporter from the New York Tribune
during which Seligman described Gould as
quote the most misunderstood most
important and most complex entrepreneur
of this century Seligman's said he found
it ironic that Gould was always cast as
the Archdemon in any telling of the
nation's recent financial history if
Gould was a sinner as Seligmann exactly
who were the Saints Seligman ran down
the list of contenders starting with
Cornelius Vanderbilt the foul-mouthed
and brutal old Commodore never claimed
to have any agenda other than his own
aggrandizement was he really to be
reviewed on one famous occasion when
asked to contribute to the poor
Vanderbilt had cited his modest
beginnings and then pointing to a line
of people waiting for gred said without
a hint of irony let them do what I have
done
next Seligman called up the memory of
Daniel drew the pious founder of the
drew Theological Seminary with whom
Gould and Jim Fisk had joined forces to
defeat Vanderbilt and gain control of
the Erie Railroad the bible-thumping
drew had started his career herding
cattle across the Alleghenies in the
1820s then he brought his habits as a
drover to Wall Street watering stocks
just as he'd always watered his beef was
mr. drew really any better than mr.
Gould Seligman asked and what of john d
the avid competition crushing monopolist
whose exclusive freight contracts
spurred by ghouls clever involvement of
Rockefeller in a secret partnership
controlling a lucrative Erie Railroad
subsidiary had played such a key role in
the Gould controlled Erie why as
Seligman is Rockefeller held and so much
higher esteem than Gould in the public
mind certainly Gould was shady at time
said Seligman mentioning in particular
that lengthy experiment and stock
manipulation dubbed the Erie Wars but
Seligman said he did not see Gould as
any more or less criminal than most
operators of his era I can't say that
mr. Gould was in his moral nature much
better much worse or much different than
any other shrewd and sharp player of his
generations at Seligmann I've known them
all I've known Jay Gould better than
most and I can tell you he deserves no
more notoriety than those against which
and with which he played if he was
exceptional it was as a strategist he
had a certain gene as genius time and
time again
Wall Street never saw him coming
ignoring Seligman's plea three
generations of biographers taking their
cues from the nearly uniform bad press
gruel received in life built him into an
evil genius of almost vaghn Aryan
proportions dark soulless unstoppable in
his history of the great American
fortunes 1909 Gustavus Myers copied the
tone of the first bot potboiler BIOS
from the 1890s when he described Gould
as quote a human carnivore blooding on
the blood of his numberless victims a
gambler destitute of the usual gamblers
code of fairness and abiding by the
rules and incarnate fiend of a
Machiavelli in his calculations Matthew
Joseph sent a socialist at the time he
put together his depression here a book
the robber barons created an entirely
damning portrait of Gould as a heartless
thief and confidence man no human
instinct of just
or patriotism or pity cause Gould to
deceive himself said Josephson or to
waver in any predictable degree from the
steadfast pursuit of strategic power and
liquid assets then 28 years later
Richard O'Conner did little more than
parrot Josephson in his bestseller Gould
millions in fact in all the years since
Jays death in 1892 only two excellent
but obscure academic biographies for
business historians Julius rodents Keys
Jay Gould his business career in 1957
and Morrie Klein's the life and legend
of Jay Gould 1986 have provided balanced
substantial and reasonable accounts of
Gould brilliant professional history
thus through the years gold has been
cobbled down in the popular mind to the
ultimate one-dimensional villain of
American financial life a talented and
highly opportunistic Wall Street leech
benefiting from the Commerce created by
others the whole interest of Gould
Robert regal wrote in the story of the
Western railroads 1926 lay in
manipulation of the securities of his
various companies the development of the
roads was an entirely minor concern in
all cases the property was to be used to
his aid his financial transactions but
the case for Gould as exemplary
successful long-term CEO is there to be
made the highly imaginative ruthless and
easy to vilify Gilded Age manipulator of
securities markets was also a
detail-oriented owner of companies a
workaholic who painstakingly
consolidated dying railroads transformed
them into highly profitable mega lines
and then did the same in maximizing the
profitability of the Western Union
skillfully steering all his concerns
including the Manhattan elevated through
choppy economic seas in the 1880s other
aspects of ghouls dark legends collapsed
just as easily under scrutiny for
example much has always been made of
ghouls will in which he left
not one dime to any charity and that's
true enough but few have noted Gould
significant philanthropies in life
efforts that good words works that he
transacted anonymously once he realized
the press would allow no good deed of
his to go unpunished
rules few publicized gestures of charity
were all greeted with derision by the
New York Times the New York Herald and
other papers bent on castigating him
every one of Gul's philanthropic
endeavors of which reporters got wind
were portrayed as inadequate feeble
gestures at face-saving that tail beside
the weight of the man's presumed grave
sins thus after several such experiences
google no longer publicized is giving
nevertheless he still continued to give
usually with the explicit requirement
that his name not be brought up in
connection with whatever good work was
at hand
in turn the press criticized him for his
lack of charity the good deeds of this
man must have been more than unusually
unobtrusive to have so completely
escaped notice commented the New York
world in October of 1891 it is
incredible that his life should have
been devoid of them but neither in
number nor in kind have they been
sufficient to extort admiration or
create imitators then we also have ghoul
the human being whom one encountered
face to face across a table or on a
street corner here he is painted by
Josephson and company brusque intolerant
Curt and cruel dismissive of underlings
blisteringly critical always
self-satisfied and never loyal to anyone
not of his blood as Robert wash out put
it in Jay Gould the story of a fortune
1928 ghouls allies quote were many but
none his friends at one time or another
in his life he broke almost every man
who worked with him but in fact Gould
long-term colleagues over the course of
decades included Russell Sage the Ames
family of Boston Sidney Dylan and
numerous others who linked their
fortunes with his and
never betrayed on a personal level his
household domestic servants including
several to whom he awarded college
scholarships
remembering remembered him fondly
decades after he was dead as well the
reportedly unapproachable Jay maintained
close relationships to the very last
year of his life with the majority of
the friends he'd made during his
impoverished Catskills boyhood most of
them humble farmers and merchants the
one really successful fellow that he'd
grown up with John Burroughs the one
fellow who was sort of on the same
playing field with Jay was the one
fellow he didn't keep in touch with but
all of Jays pals we went back again and
again to visit and who he invited down
to his mansions time and time again
we're dairy farmers falsely caricatured
by the press in life Gould has been
sentenced to the same fate and death
although guilty of every crime
transacted by his generation of American
capitalists Gould operations were
nevertheless no more sinister than those
of the financier Zinn industrialists
against whom he competed with such great
success men whose personal reputations
have soared above his over the past
century in the end Gould chief public
relations era seems to have been his
overarching success his antagonists in
business after having been burned by him
provided grist for the mills of a hungry
press when they dubbed him the
mephistopheles of Wall Street along with
the New York Tom's it was easier and
more nurturing to the pride of the
wounded to suggest a pact with Satan
than to admit that Jay was in fact the
Michelangelo of Wall Street a genius who
crafted financial devices and strategies
and leveraged existing laws in
stunningly and wonderfully original ways
now Gould story is it's too important to
get wrong his impact on his country on
his era was truly profound monumentally
large a recent inflation-adjusted
listing of the all-time richest
Americans this comparing fortunes as
percentages of GNP
place cooled in 8th place now to put
this in context for you I'll explain
that Google comes in behind john d
rockefeller at number one Cornelius
Vanderbilt number two John Jacob Astor
three he comes out ahead of Henry Ford
eleven Andrew Mellon twelve Sam Walton
fourteen JPMorgan twenty three and this
is the killer Bill Gates thirty-one well
that kind of puts him in in in in tissue
context Jai's success was profound his
productivity was astonishing and is his
motivations and his tactics were
fascinating it's like one watching a
great chess chess master at work in in
embarking upon this new full biography
of Jay Gould my aim has been to create a
true unbiased picture of Gould as both a
financier and a man with regard to
business the business that Google
conducted I have intended to serve as
neither his prosecutor nor his defense
attorney but just to lay out the facts
as we have them with regard to Gould
personal life my purpose has been to
fill the vast gap left by previous
biographers and some I have sought to
present for what I believe is the first
time an informed objective and
integrated depiction of Google in all
his complex and and frequently
conflicting guises unpredictable Wall
Street pirate level-headed manager of
corporations and dynastic Pater familias
so there you have it the book in a
nutshell it's raised on that I hope
you'll pursue it I hope you'll find it
of interest I hope you'll enjoy it and I
hope you have some questions
thank you if you do have questions you
have to wait for a second
[Applause]
Thank You Vera if you do have questions
you have to raise your hand and then you
have to wait for the gentleman with the
microphone from c-span because although
I can hear you the the country at large
won't be able to hear him if you don't
wait for the wait for the microphone so
who's who's first oh now you got it no
you it a great deal of money they came
that was used for the expansion at that
particular time with English money yes
and that so did the English suffer
tremendously did they lose their money
yeah a lot of European investors British
and also a large number of German
investors as well there's a lot of
European money generally in the market
at that time especially in the
railroading for whatever reason I think
I think the view generally was that
railroading was the the new technology
was the growth area and you know it was
the the the e-commerce of that day and
so there was a great attraction to it
but unfortunately for those investors it
was always it was also the area that was
most open to to fraud and manipulation
many of the railroads had the authority
to to to Vishal issue convertible bonds
to raise revenue to invest in
infrastructure and these convertible
bonds could be converted obviously into
stock and it led to frequently scenarios
where money was raised for
infrastructure improvements that
actually went to line the pockets of
executives in the railroad and and then
the bonds thus created were converted
into stock and the value of all the
stock went down you know and
it was it was a chronic thing with those
those securities at that time a lot of
people got burned thinking about this
subject before I came here if you read
you can make a case that Theodore
Roosevelt's political career started
when he took on Jay Gould and judge
Westbrook in the New York Assembly and
yet in Theodore Roosevelt's
autobiography I can find no reference to
Jay Gould as a person and in his eighth
Walliams of correspondence printed I
don't find any reference to Jay Gould
and I find that amazing and I like your
comments on that I think I feel a rose
well one point one thing about Theodore
Roosevelt was he didn't like to dwell on
his failures and when when TR as a young
upstart assemblyman in in Albany New
York tried to go out against Jay Gould
and against the corrupt judges generally
in the New York Supreme Court including
George Westbrook and trigger an
investigation of the doings of the
buying and selling of justice in New
York State which which Gould by the way
was not the only fellow doing Vanderbilt
during the during the Erie Wars Gould
and Vanderbilt were bidding for judges
you know so all sides of the team we're
doing that but when when Roosevelt tried
to trigger an investigation it came to
nothing and he was ultimately defeated
by Gould so uh so I could see TR not
dwelling on Gould because because duels
Gould won that round and they they
subsequently had
no interaction at all because a ghoul
died in 1892 which is well before TR had
any significant power and although
interestingly interestingly given that
history of Gould trying to get Jay Gould
and failing when in the 1920s when money
was being raised to rebuild a Theodore
Roosevelt birthplace in Manhattan one of
the principal contributors to that
effort was Helen Gould Shepard Jay Gould
Zelda's eldest daughter so there's a bit
of irony for you I was just going to ask
what did his children do oh okay um they
they would they were quite a range those
kids he had two girls Helen Anana and he
had what four boys of George Edwin
Howard and Frank so six six kids all
told and they were quite a mixed bag all
all all good people you know worthy
people unfortunately what happened was
the the eldest son George Jay Gould who
was put in charge of the family trust
after Jay died and was supposed to be
the head of the family and and the
leader of the pack was the the least
equipped among them for that task he was
not a good business man he was not
diligent he preferred to relax and play
tennis and party and and and didn't do
his homework and it showed rather
quickly when and when Gould died he had
set up a very complex trust that was
just devised and designed to
you keep his family together and keep
the fortune together what he did was he
put his entire wealth which was
conservatively appraised for tax
purposes 72 million it was actually more
like 125 million put all as well into
one trust that and left the residual
income on that trust to his six children
and to to their descendants purse trips
as it as because it's called so each
line no matter how much it multiplied
would just get 1/6 of them and with the
one exception to that being if if a line
died out then the pie would be carved up
in the fifths and fourths and so on
and they were supposed they were each
equal trustees in the trust once
everyone had come of age and they were
supposed to vote and agree on policies
and procedures and investments with the
one caveat that George Jay Gould had a
veto vote and and could could run the
show and unfortunately did and ran it
into the ground by the by the teens of
the of the 20th century the the younger
children the younger heirs of Jay Gould
were suing George and their older
siblings for mismanagement of the trust
a circus tent full of lawyers divided
our de bout 20 million dollars in fees
over the course of about eight years by
the time it would all the dust settled
George Jay Gould was dead he died rather
early in the 1920s and and the the the
corpus of the trust was around 40
million bear in mind it had been around
125 million in real terms in 1892 so and
it was placed in under the guidance of
professional managers thereafter and put
in conservative investments
and it still exists it still pays out
various sums but there's a lot of Google
descendants as a lot and most of them
have day jobs they do consider such a
terrible person considering all the
others as you've been talking that's
been effective all amount of bad they
were just as bad as he was but why was
he just you know plagued awful yeah I I
think part of it is that he had a very
bad sense of residual post mortem PR
where up these other people had a very
good sense of it you know to Carnegie
you know his Carnegie Hall it's a
Carnegie Endowment there's Carnegie
Mellon University there's cool there's
not cool Gould his name's not on
anything you know yo yeah yeah oh right
he didn't do that
right and he didn't do it he done the
time he didn't yeah but see me yeah I
write it well he didn't do it in life
either you know and and there was a
period right after the the Black Friday
1869 the era into the early 1870s when J
actually sort of cultivated this this
dark mystique and wanted people to think
he was you know not the greatest guy
didn't he didn't go out and say I'm I'm
I'm the meanest guy on the block but he
didn't contradict other people when they
said it either and he considered this a
valuable tool for a while as a source of
business this idea of his dark
inevitability and he was attracted to it
and his personal secretary and sometime
bodyguard a fellow by the name of
Morosini
wrote extensively after TJ died about
various conversations and had with Jay
through the years and more see any
documents that you know there were times
when when morosini said we should
repudiate what the what Jamie Bennett is
saying about you that's not true we
should you know get out there and
repudiate it classic PR you know and Jay
said no we're not going we're not going
to say anything we'll just let it what a
right
but then Morosini also relates about ten
years later than a conference in one of
the last conversations he had with Gould
where Gould talked talked to Morosini
about the fact that maybe he had
miscalculated in this and his fear he
didn't he never cared about himself and
that was part of the equation too he
didn't care about his reputation but he
cared about his family and he cared
about his children and in one of the
last conversations he had with Morosini
and i morosini quoted him and i use the
quote as a title for one of my chapters
near the end of the book he told
morosini i'm paraphrasing was too close
paraphrasing my grave fear is that i
shall be able to leave my children
everything but a good name and his his
huge muscle 'i'm at Woodlawn to this day
there is no name on it the name Gould is
not on that mausoleum it's inside if
you've got what you know get the key and
go in that's in there but the outside of
the mausoleum does not indicate who's
inside to get together with Helen was
that business family meetings or the
Helen who he married of her we're we're
not a hundred percent sure how they
connected both but we can speculate when
J came to New York City you know in the
early 1860s very early 1860s he was
living in in a hotel right off of Union
Square enough at a Murray Hill area and
he lived the the hotel where he lived
was very close by the home where
our Helen day Miller as her maiden name
was had been raised and where she was
living as a young lady with her parents
her father being a very successful
investor himself and she was kind of a
sort of a flower of Murray Hill Society
now we don't know the details of how
they met some some biographers have
speculated that you know he was in the
neighborhood she was in the neighborhood
they met on the street but that just
wasn't done especially in Murray Hill so
my theory is that he may have
encountered Helens father in the course
of doing business and that Helens father
may have thought him a worthy catch for
her
because Jay was somewhat unique among he
was a street trader on Wall Street at
that time these fellows were literally
on the street on Wall Street trading
stocks it was very rough and tumble and
he was a young guy you know feeling his
way earning earning his bones you know
and and trying to get a grubstake
together and but unlike most of those
fellows Jay was very temperate soul he
most of these guys were really real
party animals that's what I'm trying to
say and Jay wasn't he was very
industrious and very straight-laced his
father had been an alcoholic he had no
alcohol had no real appeal to him
nightlife had no real appeal to him his
instincts were very domestic he liked to
read he liked to garden and so I could
see a father maybe thinking that he'd be
a good catch so my speculation is that
the father brought him home and
introduced him now and also in some
biographies they say the parents were
against the marriage and the couple
eloped and all this but at the New York
Historical Society there's a very good
collection of papers that I used a great
deal in working on this book
and it's it's a large collection of
reminiscences that Helen Gould the
daughter asked Jays sisters and brother
and business associates everyone who had
known him even John Burroughs to write
boyhood friends later business friend
she a year or two after Jay died she
asked everybody to write their
reminiscences and she had the thought
that she was going to do a biography of
her father based on that she never got
to it but she saved papers and Jays one
of Jays sisters the the others couldn't
make it but one of Jays sisters speaks
of coming to the Miller home and Murray
Hill for the wedding of Jay and Helen
and remembers the wedding and the date
now and there is also even in that
collection a printed invitation to the
wedding so there was no elopement it was
all very you know just as you'd expect
it to be duh that New York Historical
Society collection was a huge boon to me
that's where I got all those morosini
reminiscences and a lots of great
material about Jay as a kid and as a
young man up in Roxbury in the Catskills
before he got out of there before he you
know it started making his way in the
world and he spent 20 years you he lived
56 years and he spent 20 of them in this
little town in the Catskills so his you
know good story and that that was the
place of Genesis for him and it's very
interesting there's this teacher in this
little one-room schoolhouse that these
kids went to was a fellow by the name of
James Oliver who it's very interesting
to me he had about seven or eight boys
in this room and granted you know four
or five of them stayed local and became
a dairy men and you know did nothing
extraordinary
but three of them
John burrows Jay Gould and another
another fellow ah John Champlin went on
to lead extraordinary lives Joan Chaplin
ended his days as the Chief Justice of a
Michigan State Supreme Court John
burrows was of John Burroughs and his
rule was Gould and each all three of
those fellows as old men or at least
schooled as old as a god 50 in his 50s
looked back to Oliver and commented on
him and called this talked about what a
remarkable man he was and sort of paid
homage to him it was very interesting
and Gould when he was he would go Gould
would go out west once every year and
ride every mile of his roads he had a
private railroad car they pulled behind
a private engine and he would go I would
be out there for three months and he
just wanted to see every station in
every road this is the micromanager
Gould the CEO you know you know he
wanted to get off and he wanted to talk
to the brakeman in Kansas you know and
see you know how does that new brake
working that we bought you know but this
fellow Oliver James Oliver had a after
as a young man he had gotten married and
he'd moved out to Kansas and Gould
would stop every year and visit James
Oliver every year and if James Oliver
ever wanted something I'm not sure he
did but if he ever did I'm pretty sure
he got it cools also made frequent trips
back to Roxbury as he matured and
usually on flying visits got on his way
to some more important destination but
if he was coming within screaming
distance of his old hometown he'd
stopped you know he'd spend a day or two
and in 1888 when he was already
diagnosed with the tuberculosis that he
knew was going to kill him he brought
most of his children not the old the
older ones were offering their own thing
but most of his children and many
nephews and nieces along with him and
spent about a week in Roxbury
he went there in his private railroad
car and he had it brought pulled up on a
siding of the Ulster in Delaware
railroad and had it parked and he
normally as I alluded to in my talk he
normally traveled with five or six
fairly burly Pinkertons because people
did want to hurt him he was widely
despised as soon as they got to Roxbury
he sent the detectives ways that I don't
need you here I'm good I'm home you know
and they went away and he spent several
days walking the streets of Roxbury
visiting the graves of his mother and
father and aunts and uncles and and in
introducing his children and nephews and
nieces to their cousins in the area and
going up to the old Gould farm outside
of town and and and also going to the
farm of this fellow Peter Van Amburg who
who had been the hired man on the Gould
farm when Gould was just a few years
younger older than Gould and he had been
the hired man on Gould family farm and
and later worked in a tin business that
the ghouls had briefly and and was a
great old friend of Jays and they went
out to the whole group of them went out
to Peter's farm and had a country
breakfast and then Gould who was feeling
pretty good that day at this point he
had good days and bad days but it was a
day when he was feeling pretty good and
he and Peter walked the length and
breadth of Peters farm and talked about
old Todd and Peter was a very thrifty
a Delaware County farmer very you know
knew where every nickel was and you know
one of these guys and you know cheap you
know and Gould Gould told as he was
leaving he Gould Ghul's daughter wrote
the sub construes and witness to it as
and also Peter wrote it up to himself
later too as they were leaving Peter's
farm Gould said Peter gone on brewery
said now you will have to come and see
my farm as a state Lind Harrison on
tarry town on the Hudson River and
because I'd like to show you my farm and
Peter said well I'd love to but you know
I'm
you know real busy and you know and the
train ticket is like you know sixty
cents or something and you know and I
don't have time I gotta you know it's
good to see you you know come back
anytime but I'm not going down there
and J knowing here said if if you come
visit me
I'll give you your pick of the Lyndhurst
herd to take back with you as a present
though sheep and because J knew this
would work sure enough two weeks later
on the door of Lyndhurst Peter Van
Amburg and his Sunday best come to visit
and claim his cow him as J was delighted
to see him he took him on a tour of the
castle you know if you Millie with Linda
hers but it's like a castle the house
it's where they shot film dark shadows
in the 1960s that's Linda Harris J's
have and took him on a tour of the
castle on a tour of the ground and then
J had some business to transact out of
Manhattan so didn't J took off from
Manhattan said he'd be back in a few
hours
and he left P Peter Van Amburg in the
company of his fellow Ferdinand mongold
who was a German who was the
groundskeeper and basically ran the
estate at Lyndhurst and subsequently ran
to other states for Google's children
but Annie told mango let him take him
out to the field and let him tick you
know whatever animal he wants to three
hours later Jay comes back mangled and
Van Amburg is sitting in the the living
room at Lyndhurst Peter Van Amburg has a
big grin on his face couldn't be happier
mangled muttering and we're cursing in
Reena and J says de Mangal what's wrong
and Anglesey he picked our prize bull
the the best the best we've got and
court according to a according to Helen
of J's looked at Peter and said Peter I
always knew you're a smart one I'll give
I'll send you the pedigree papers and
I'll tell you the shipping and the cow
is you know the bull is yours and by
this time actually
it was very touching and on Van Amburg
account that he wrote after Jay died he
said that he remembered that by this
time Gould was really you know the
tuberculosis was really starting to
catch up with him and he was coughing
incessantly and basically couldn't sleep
just couldn't sleep and he because he
couldn't lay down so he had to sit up
and yeah and Peter was spending the
night at Lyndhurst before going home and
he remembered that he and Jays sat up
all night together and you know talked
over all times you know and had ever had
a real fine time but he that's the kind
you know that's the kind of humanizing
stories like okay this guy you know you
know just isn't Dracula you know you
know and that that really impressed me
and any and he showed signs throughout
his life of not being snob it's
interesting because he bootstrapped
himself out up out of nothing
you know just nothing and a time and
time and time again you see him showing
respect for and facilitating other
people who are come in the process of
coming from nothing who want a bootstrap
is these are the people that he can
relate to he a very interesting thing I
uncovered that no one else had it hasn't
been in any other rulebook at Lyndhurst
in Tarrytown and at his mansion down on
Fifth Avenue
he had very large extensive private
libraries big libraries that he actually
read he was a very bookish fellow he
read and random rhetoric he gave the the
household staff at each place which
tended to be youngish people generally a
carte blanche access to those libraries
they were welcome to use those libraries
come in and grab a book even if he was
in that you know it wasn't like oh mr.
Gould in there I can't go in there now
even if he was in there you know as long
as they didn't you know play music I
guess you know they were welcome to come
in and grab a book and you know and but
what which was great
you know that's peachy but then what I
observed
and deduced from the correspondence and
the diaries that I heard that I came
across and the memoirs he was using this
as a method of triaging people he so he
watched and saw who took him up on that
offer okay and then not a few of these
young people wound up being banked to go
to college by Gould he would you know
make an offer you know say you know and
you know there's more than one carriage
livery boy or or maid who wound up is I
mean they didn't wind up as CEOs but
they wound up as accountants or school
teachers because Gould said look you're
too smart for this let's you know let's
get you to NYU you know and he did it
several times you know he did it you
know about that I can document about 12
times you know I'm probably more you
know and he when when his his wife had
sort of these pretensions and she was
very Mary Hill you know and she was
outraged and and and beside herself when
their oldest son George Jay Gould
married an act got engaged to an actress
who came had been raised in a slum in
Brooklyn you know and and and said no no
no this can never be and Jay said no it
can be you know and you know that's
they're in love and that's that you know
and and he facilitated the wedding and
when a day after the wedding when the
New York Times reporter from the New
York Times happened the corner him he
didn't like to talk to the press
generally but every once in a while he'd
get stuck in a corner and have to answer
a question when he got cornered a day
after the wedding and they were asking
him what do you think about you know
George marrying an actress you know
oh and actors you know after uh he said
look you know I'm paraphrasing again but
it's a close paraphrase she went on the
stage to support her mother I respect
that you know that's how she could make
money you know she did what she had to
do to put bread on the table what's
wrong with that you know
you know so he personally and he and in
his organizations he always insisted in
part this was you know not being a snob
and being altruistic but and part of his
also self-preservation just made good
managerial sense
he insisted on promoting from within you
know if you're going to get somebody to
marry manage ten brakeman have it to
somebody who's been a brakeman for the
last eight years because he knows how to
you know that kind of thing and he most
of most of the mid-level and and in even
some of the higher level executives in
his various organizations were people
who would you know come up you know and
he frequently made you know sort of calm
you know he would make in the press
skating comments about when when Charles
Francis Adams was trying to seize
control of the Union Pacific away from
Jay you know he said all you know these
Harvard guys you know they just think
they can you know you know so he kind of
had that reverse you know snobbery going
to so anyone else thank you
[Applause]